[Applause]
[Music]
ldbl immediately Kaka plenty o da vamos
a la fuerza sara ma de por dios nosotros
no pero neeta's contra military somos
una coporate ido politico be gentle tina
from da da da
in the realm of politics Argentina is
something like a royal wedding for
gossip columns it's impossible to stop
them from getting all of the attention
and all of the headlines and in this
case a ton of videos on visual politic
and what can I say it's no wonder from a
political standpoint the case of
Argentina is very exciting that is
precisely why to date we've already
published more than 15 videos about the
land of tango videos where we have
talked a lot about different topics but
we still need to examine one of the most
common political issues trade unions and
their enormous power in Argentinian
politics
in this video we're gonna see how far
the power of trade unions really goes
but first we have to see where it all
began
[Music]
Argentina and its dreams
in Argentinean is watching this video
probably think that the whole history of
trade unions began with heron ISM in the
1940s it's how the story usually goes
within the country yet nothing is
further from the truth
the history of trade unionism in
Argentina dates back much further to get
a better understanding we have to go
back to roughly the end of the 19th
century that was Argentina's golden era
it was a contender to be the richest
country in the world investments were
pouring in and millions and millions of
people chose this place to start a new
life in fact during the last decades of
the 19th century Argentina was receiving
the second largest number of immigrants
only surpassed by the United States at
that time the American dream could be
realized at the bottom of the continent
as well the Argentinian dream was real
and that's the time when trade unions
first began to emerge they were driven
by the immigrants themselves who flocked
to the country and used them as a way to
organize themselves in order to improve
their living conditions in a country
they did not know and where most did not
yet have political rights
in this way unions gradually grew and
gained more and more influence for
example in the 1920s the country's
economic strength together with the
demands of the trade unions themselves
led to the implementation of the first
measures regarding the length of the
working-day minimum working ages and the
rights of workers however the real
turning points of this whole story
occurred in the 1940s On June the 4th
1943 there was a coup as it would
forever changed Argentina's history
shortly after the military coup then
colonel juan domingo perón was placed in
charge of the new labor department
Colonel Peron trained initially during
the 1930s as a reminder that was when
Italy was a fascist state ad by many
time of celini during those years and
amidst pizza risotto and spaghetti Iran
discovered just how important it could
be to organize the labor movement from a
powerful position
[Music]
and that's exactly what did from within
the Labor Department slowly without
rushing but with a consistent effort he
began co-opting the unions it started
with the smaller ones he offered them
benefits in exchange for commitments and
agreements with governments or rather
with himself
[Music]
in this way Peron built a whole network
of trade unions that he effectively
controls and that were loyal to him in
fact the more faithfully union was to
him the more benefits they received from
the government all this put Braun in a
very privileged position he soon became
the most influential politician in the
country and that's what ended up taking
him all the way to Casa Rosada the
Argentinian White House of course when
perón became presidency pushed this
political strategy even further until
the majority of trade unions became part
of the Parana Sparty itself in fact
socialist or communist trade unions that
refused to swear allegiance to Peron
were persecuted and on rare occasions
rebel unions were intercepted and came
under official control the message was
here either with me or against me
if you swore allegiance to Iran that was
the carrot and if not you'd get the
stick
and not only that during his years in
power Perron nationalized a lot of
companies and hired a lot of public
employees with very attractive labor
benefits this was a process largely
controlled by the unions who were loyal
to Perron themselves
they wear his spearhead for example in
1955 when Braun himself was overthrown
by a military coup and pran and his
party were outlawed the unions became
the conveyor belt of perónist influence
in Argentina they became the main
opposing force to the new dictatorship a
dictatorship that was ironically bestow
on them their greatest privilege in 1970
after a popular insurrection known as
the court of Bazo general Han Carlos on
Jania who ran the country at that time
did something for the unions that not
even Perron himself a dead due he
granted them the administration of the
social works department to workers
health service this meant putting
hundreds of millions of dollars in the
hands of Argentinian unions without any
external control not surprisingly it was
precisely this move the made Argentinian
trade unions some of the most powerful
trade unions in the world
they were organizations led by an elite
that became untouchable
[Music]
Kali's the new monarchy suddenly
Argentinian trade unions became very
powerful instruments they had political
influence a great capacity for
mobilization and they controlled
millions and millions of dollars since
then their influence has only increased
to give you an idea today between 17 and
20 million Argentines pay into and
receive medical care from the Union
Health Services once more over the years
these organizations have extended their
tentacles far beyond today they even
controlled hotels universities and media
this makes argentine trade unions the
most powerful on the planet they've
essentially built up an empire but wait
a moment because all of this also causes
some problems and a fundamental one has
everything to do with control I mean
we're talking about huge organizations
with million-dollar budgets that are
managed with few restrictions that means
if you are the head of a union you
become one of the most important people
in Argentina suddenly you have access to
a lot of influence and a lot of money
[Music]
everyone answers your calls everyone
listens to what you have to say you are
practically untouchable many people that
you have placed or promoted to different
positions depends on you and as we're
going to see everybody wants to do
business with you so the question is why
on earth wouldn't you make the most of
it
in Argentina trade unions have become
like new political parties with exactly
the same perverse incentives or an
example well look the union leaders of
most associations have remained
basically unchanged more than 30 years
yes there are supposedly elections but
of course when you've been at the helm
of an organization for so long well you
control all the buttons this is exactly
the same with governments and the reason
why many democracies have a limitation
on the duration of leadership so that no
politician is tempted to keep themselves
in power but let's look at some specific
examples there is the case of Rahman
ball tasini from the Federation of
employees of posts and
telecommunications he was at the helm of
the Union for a grand total of 55 years
from 1963 until 2018 then there's a
Marva biani the secretary-general of the
taxi drivers union he's been there for
more than 35 years amedeo gender the
municipal workers union has been a 35
years guillermo Perea oil union more
than 35 years or Rodolfo dare in the
food sector for more than 33 years as a
comparison these guys have been in
charge longer than any dictator on the
planet except Teodoro Obiang
the dictator of Equatorial Guinea so
let's hope he doesn't find out or I'll
be packing his bags and headed to
Argentina to drawing the trade unionists
and remember these are just a few
examples millions it doesn't matter if
the country economic conditions or
government's change the union bosses
remain the same in Argentina it is
common for these leaders to spend
decades at the helm of trade unions
sparer has even been the case of union
leaders who have handed down their
powerful positions to distant relatives
in Argentina the parties the business
leadership the armed forces even the
church have all changed but unions have
remained in the same hands 30 years on
how do they do it because they're
functional to power even the military
agreed with them there is always a sense
that without trade unionists Argentina
could not be governed regardeth of God
bana Argentinian journalist as you can
imagine all this has consequences trade
unions cease to be plural organizations
and become hierarchical structures
what's more as time passes things change
but these rigid structures
can't adapt and of course in the end
there are so many vested interests that
you end up not really knowing what or
who you're defending at this point some
of you might be thinking but hold on
Simon with unions so strong and so
influential Argentinian workers must be
the most protected in the world right
well actually no they're not the
country's constant economic crisis and
out-of-control inflation rates have
caused real wages ie the purchasing
power of Argentinian workers to remain
stagnant for decades and what's worse
work is scarce unemployment is high and
almost 40 percent of the employees in
the country are informal workers these
are workers you have much less security
and far fewer rights
[Music]
so in other words if we had to evaluate
Argentinean trade unions for their
results and their influence on
argentinian politics i think the grades
would be so low that they'd need to
spend at least the next ten summers
having to revise to capture and look
let's take a moment because i know many
of you are in favor of trade unions i'm
not saying that the problem is that
there are unions not at all
but perhaps having such a large
structure that's so powerful so fixed in
their ideas and with so many vested
interests makes changing course
practically an impossible mission
Argentina's just a good example of this
but so much money and power in
organizations like these also leads to
other problems test cream acidity in
articulation Andre L capital yell drama
[Music]
over the last few years orphans Indian
trade unions have been shaken by a great
many scandals and now some of the mighty
kings of fall
this is the case for example of omec bio
Suarez who was head of the port workers
union and one of Cristina Fernandez de
Kirchner 'he's favorite trade unionists
caballo Suarez has been prosecuted for
unlawful Association aggravated coercion
and fraudulent administration during the
investigation many great luxuries were
revealed his home located in one of the
most expensive areas of Buenos Aires
yacht cigars bottles of champagne
caballo Suarez was living the high life
another example is the case of Juan
Pablo Potter Medina one of the former
leaders of u ocra the construction
workers union he was arrested in 2007
for unlawful association money
laundering and extortion is estimated
this in the five years prior to his
arrest he ran illegal operations that
netted him more than ten million dollars
between 2013 and 2017 alone real estate
expensive jewelry this union leader even
had a money counting machine in his home
and lots of luxury cars to give you an
idea during the investigation more than
a hundred caused 3 million dollars in
jewelry and even a plane and helicopter
were found this guy looked more like a
character out of Grand Theft Auto than a
union leader
cabins
no celibacy doe another union leader
this time in the education sector was
also caught detained in November 2018 he
was found in possession of bank accounts
in cash totaling more than seven million
dollars among his assets were two
aircraft a yacht several Porsches a
Ferrari and a Mercedes McLaren supercar
the guy even at his own zoo and more
than 35 employees at his service he
basically lived like a Maharajah anyway
these are just three examples from a
very long list many union leaders used
their positions to amass true fortunes
and live like kings and they did so for
decades with total impunity as well the
country moved from one crisis to another
so unions can play an important role but
is it really a good idea for them to
control that much money shouldn't the
Argentinian government insist on more
transparency and control to prevent all
of this money and power being held by an
elite isn't it time they did an honest
self-assessment and recognized that the
role of the unions over the past few
decades has contributed to many of
Argentina's current problems after all
Argentinian trade unions have been
fervent policy advocates for more taxes
or protectionism and more labor
regulations these are policies that have
done enormous damage to the country so
isn't it time for some change and I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also please do check
out our friends at the reconsider media
podcast they've provided the vocals in
this episode that were not mine also
this channel is possible because of
patreon ends our patrons on that
platform please do consider joining them
and supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always see you in the next video if you
want to learn more about politics and
world affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider at
WWE consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]